welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and along with the cryptic imagery
of patrick stewart as charles xavier
leading the illuminati and doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness is
an even weirder shot showing this
facility's detention sector in which an
alternate universe christine palmer
works alongside ultron sentries guardian
multiversal prisoners like america
chavez so much is going on here it's
like kevin feige shook up his toy box
and dumped it back out so now red
skull's running the tba wearing iron man
armor actually that sounds awesome can
we get that as a what if episode i mean
isn't this kind of thing all marvel has
ever been but i think there is a clear
answer to charles xavier's true
importance to this organization how they
are able to track multiversal fugitives
and why it's so dangerous to have a
pissed-off scarlet witch in this museum
because throughout the x-men films what
has been the greatest tool and weapon in
charles xavier's arsenal the physical
embodiment of his mental capacity
cerebro cerebro follows charles
everywhere and i believe in multiverse
of madness that hyde network has been
expanded to a multiversal horizon to
give us a road map of all the marvel
universes now being annexed to the mcu
cerebral's origin really began with the
x-men themselves dating back to x-men
number seven in 1964 when it was really
more of a wiry web cerebros showed up
throughout the x-men 90s animated series
first in season 1 episode 3 when charles
uses the helmet to track magneto
revealing some pretty hilarious
animation gaffes with his tie where are
you
i know you're close
[Music]
professor professor xavier
charles are you all right
oh i'm fine storm really
you're looking for that magneto guy
you've been here all night it was 1992
shut your mouth now this cerebral was
built using alien shiar technology by
charles and magneto a partnership that
was held true in cerebro's live-action
redesign in the 2000 x-men film this
device amplifies my power allowing me to
locate mutants across great distances
why don't you just use it to find
magneto i've been trying but he seems to
have found some way to shield himself
from it how would he know how to do that
because he helped me build it this
cerebro technology was weaponized in x2
when colonel striker logan roy brian cox
used secrets interrogated out of magneto
to build a cerebro replica in the alkali
lake facility where striker's son jason
striker manipulated charles's mind to
link with and kill all mutants until
magneto and mystique reversed it so that
charles nearly killed all humans instead
then when the x-men franchise was
rebooted in matthew vaughn's prequel
x-men first class cerebro was a project
built by hank mccoy for the cia in the
1960s and charles xavier helped them use
this version of cerebro to find other
mutants a process that had the same
misty aesthetic as it did in the
2000-2003 films and leads them to logan
excuse me i'm eric lynch xavier go [ __ ]
yourself now cerebro did appear in the
days of future past extended rogue cut
in which magneto and bobby drake go on a
side mission to rescue rogue from the
ruins of the x-mansion finding rogue
being operated on in the cerebral dome
bobby ends up getting killed by
sentinels during that rescue but rogue
survives so that she can take over for a
wounded kitty pride to continue
projecting logan's consciousness into
the past and meanwhile in the 1970s
timeline mystique destroys charles and
hank's upgraded cerebro facility but
since that rogue cut was removed from
the theatrical version of the film
cerebro officially survives into the
1980s in x-men apocalypse now in the
basement of the x-mansion where hank
hints that he colored it blue in honor
of raven and charles uses it to try to
find magneto but apocalypse hijacks that
link to force humans in the military to
fire all nukes into space thanks to
havoc's chest blasts that cerebral and
x-mansion also get destroyed but the
movie ends with charles and the new
x-men in a rebuilt mansion's danger room
cerebro appears again in dark phoenix
where charles uses it to navigate jean
grey's mind by the way in that film the
villains are that alien race of the
shiar the same race whose tech the
animated charles and eric based cerebral
on cerebral was also implied to exist in
the deadpool movies deadpool wore
charles's cerebral helmet in deadpool 2
and then in logan and aging charles
lives in a tank in a smeltine mill in
the mexican desert that functions as a
kind of anti-cerebro blocking charles's
mind from others now i hope you've been
paying attention because these are some
hot hot details i'm throwing your way
super hot since you know i was writing
all this on a laptop that i put on my
lap and it takes hours to write these
videos scorching these thighs now if you
are the kind of person who uses your
laptop on your lap no judgment it is in
the name but our friends at blue blocks
have a great product for you and
everybody else using a laptop that i
just started using makes a big
difference this is their anti-radiation
laptop mat that blocks harmful emf
radiation when placed between you and
your computer they also help block that
heat use this when you're answering
emails just doing work even watching new
rockstars videos it's fun to have my
theories admissible details radiating
through your brain not so fun to have
that emf and heat from your laptop
radiating through your nether regions so
blue blocks blocks it all blue blocks
products are designed in australia and
use science-backed technology that has
been lab tested their laptop mats are
now guaranteed to block up to 99 of emf
radiation i'm doing very important work
on my laptop using the blue blocks mat
and my knees have never been more
lukewarm no seriously like on a plane
recently when the person in front of me
put their seat back making it impossible
for me to use to the tray table to do
work i used this thing on my thighs and
my denim didn't melt for once blue
blocks offers other anti-radiation and
emf manda getting products like some
anti-radiation earphones and blue box
offers all kinds of wellness products
like the blue light glasses blackout
sleep masks that i just use on a flight
big difference maker and flicker in blue
light free light bulbs blue blocks ship
worldwide in rapid time and they make
returns and exchanges super easy so go
to blueblocks.com new rockstars and use
coupon code newrockstars20 to save 20
percent that's blueblocks.com
b-l-u-b-l-o-x dot com slash new
rockstars and use coupon code
newrockstars20 to save 20
so now in multiverse madness as patrick
stewart returns as charles xavier it's
only natural that he's accompanied by
his longtime technological network
because this facility in the trailer has
all the markings of xavier's grandiose
interior design charles chose the lobby
of london's british museum in keeping
with his academic idealism and love of
ancient history rulers like charlemagne
arthurian legend egyptian mythology and
how interconnected it was revealed to be
with insa nur aka the first mutant on
earth apocalypse in the detention room
where we find christine palmer the
ultron centuries american chavez purple
screens line the walls i think they may
be connected to a multiversal upgrade of
charles's cerebro network the way this
version of charles found and assembled
his illuminati lineup and how all of
them continue to patrol the multiverse
were violators of multiversal law which
is how doctor strange and american
chavez end up in their custody in the
trailer the british museum lobby centers
around a round central structure that
looks like it has an upper level with
similar windows as the ones stretching
above the courtroom chamber and then
back in that lobby you can see
additional doors that may be elevators
dropping to a basement beneath the
detention room with wooden paneling
similar to the lift doors in charles's
x-mansion that led down to the basement
where cerebral in the danger room were
located so this charles xavier may come
from a universe similar to where we were
left at the end of days of future past
where his technology was allowed to
advance unimpeded by any anti-mutant
threats like the sentinels indicated by
his nifty office hover chair which would
lead to increasingly powerful
advancements after advancements of
cerebro that would eventually allow him
to link with the minds of mutants from
other realities perhaps starting with
nexus being mutants whose psionic powers
already extend beyond their realities in
the moment we saw wanda astral
projecting to read the darkhold where
she suddenly looked up upon hearing her
son's voices
something changed in that moment many of
us thought that that could have been
linked with that rumble of thunder he
who remains heard in loki
all of this could have been a single
radar blip received by charles xavier
wearing his cerebro helmet in his
multiversal cerebro to indicate a vast
system failure and as we saw in the
x-men timeline every cerebral built is
inevitably taken over by a hostile party
to turn it into a weapon which could be
now why wanda has broken into this
facility the scarlet witch needs a
multiversal index to locate her sons and
as charles xavier nearly wiped out all
the mutants in x2 using cerebro wanda
would now have the same weapon to apply
her famous house of m line hey you can
follow me on instagram and twitter at
avos follow new rockstars and subscribe
to rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you